well this morning a Mississippi man who
has been tried six times for a quadruple
murder is free on bail for the first
time in more than 20 years a judge ruled
yesterday that Curtis flowers could
leave jail while prosecutors decide
whether to drop the charges Flowers has
been convicted four times but maintains
his innocence
the latest conviction was overturned by
the US Supreme Court Janet shamlian is
outside the courthouse in Winona
Mississippi Janet you were actually
there at his release
Jericka good morning we were as he left
the jail these were his first moments
outside of lockup in more than two
decades and Curtis flowers was
overwhelmed now to be clear this is not
total freedom but as he awaits a
possible seventh trial he can do so from
home what were your thoughts did you
think this day 49 year old Curtis
flowers walked free for the first time
in more than two decades most of its
spent on death row it's been wrong wrong
you know taking it one day at a time you
know this case is unprecedented in the
history of the American legal system
flowers was tried six times for the same
crime a quadruple murder during a
furniture store robbery in the small
town of wind owned in Mississippi the
state has failed to convince this court
that the proof of mr. flowers guilt is
evidence of the six trials two resulted
in hung juries his convictions in the
other for later reversed over misconduct
by the prosecutor his latest conviction
was overturned by the US Supreme Court
in June which ruled the prosecutor Doug
Evans tried to keep african-americans
off the jury
tell me about having your brother home
what would that be like
very joyful thankful grateful I'm still
hurting but now it's 23 years he served
as an innocent man but for the 23 years
that the family has a continued go
through this and really of this tragedy
also an anonymous donor paid twenty five
thousand dollars to secure flowers
release on bail his attorney has filed a
motion to have the case dismissed
to avoid a seventh trial ahead of that
decision flowers will be confined to his
home and where an electronic monitor a
taste of freedom he's still trying to
comprehend it's worth noting that no one
has been held accountable for those four
murders and those families are still
suffering at the bail hearing flowers
attorney said that there's new evidence
that points to at least three other
possible suspects we reached out to the
prosecutor's office to see how it
intends to handle this going forward but
have not heard back
Tony Jana thank you very much for
convictions but all of them overturn so
effectively nine right I think Curtis
your sister makes a really good point to
Tony that it doesn't just affect him it
affects the whole family a lot of people
don't think about that so he's not
totally free but it's got to feel great